all right I'm live I think it's possible
i was actually live for like the last 10
seconds it didn't know it please clap
it's time to start I'm glad people are
joining me I scheduled this one ahead of
time today and it seems like people like
the scheduling ahead of time I don't
know just my sense of it so I'm going to
talk about some of the latest news
already a whole bunch of stuff happened
after the taping of today's show we clap
we tape now we clap we tape at we're
usually done by like 130 or 140 five
Eastern to get the show out to people by
about 3 30 and a whole bunch of stuff
has already happened Sean Spicer gave a
bizarre press conference I've got a
whole agenda here i'll also be talking
about some of the books i received for
interviews that we're going to be doing
upcoming i have them here if you follow
me on instagram at david pakman you
already know what they are and people
emailing me many people with questions
about questions i should i should give
or have ready for the authors of those
books so a lot of different stuff going
on super chat is on i will also be doing
live shout outs and thank yous for
people who sign up for membership during
the stream people seem to like that i've
been doing it since i started these
streams you can of course sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership
members are big league heroes that's
that's what i call them and we do have a
coupon code i voted 17 all one word a
lowercase so that's going to be going on
by the way i think most of the people
that watch our subscribers on youtube
already that i think that you only get
notified of the live streams if you are
a subscriber but in case you're not
subscribed please subscribe to our
channel on youtube where our next
milestone is i don't know 350 thousand
subscribers four hundred thousands not
that far off we are calculating based on
this the subscriber growth of 2017 so
far we should actually hit half a
million
fibers well before the year is out but
you know things can change that's the
way the trend lines are looking right
now so I'm going to start digging into
topics send super chats as you want so
okay we've been following this entire
Trump wiretap thing a couple of weeks
ago Donald Trump sent three tweets
alleging that President Obama had
wiretapped him a couple of those tweets
had wiretap in quotation marks which was
later used by press secretary Sean
Spicer to argue that Trump didn't mean a
literal wiretap but just surveillance so
there's been a couple of different
committees including the senate
intelligence committee looking into this
and most recently they said they have no
they have seen no evidence and have no
reason to believe at this time that it's
true that President Obama or anyone
acting on his behalf wiretapped or in
any way surveilled Donald Trump so Sean
Spicer goes out there today to give a
press briefing and you know god bless
him for lack of a better term because
since day one I believe it was a day one
of Sean spices job as White House press
secretary Trump paraded him out there to
just make up stuff to try to justify
Donald Trump's obvious live that some
record inauguration turnout was had in
Washington DC for Trump's inauguration
and it hasn't gotten any better for Sean
Spicer since so anyway cut to today Sean
Spicer goes out and I was at I was at
the gym just now watching highlights of
this exchange that he had with CNN
reporter Jim Acosta and visibly angry
Sean Spicer asked whether despite the
latest statement that there's no
evidence so far than anybody on the
Senate Senate Intelligence Committee has
seen that it's true that Obama wiretap
Trump does Trump stand by the allegation
and Sean Spicer on the one hand said yes
but denied what Jim Acosta cited that
the Senate Intelligence people had said
but just two days ago said Trump didn't
literally mean wiretapping so I'm
thinking do you stand by what Trump said
or do you say that
Trump didn't really say what he said
because of the quotation marks around
wiretapping I said we should really step
back from this if the entire truth of
trumps allegation depends on quotation
marks these aren't exactly the strongest
allegations to begin with are they that
the and so everything going wrong for
Sean Spicer and to some degree I guess I
feel bad for the guy but he agreed to
take this job right how bad we really
feel and he's going out there and doing
the bidding of Donald Trump making stuff
up having to defend 325 million people
voted illegally having to defend the
inauguration crowds having to defend did
was he did he defend cow Kellyanne
Conway Bowling Green Massacre I know he
referred to his own made-up Atlanta
bombing or attack or whatever it was so
on the one hand he goes out there every
day and he just gets destroyed and
someone suggesting I hope he's getting
paid 300,000 a year I think he's getting
170 I think that that right now is the
top salary for cabinet maybe that's not
true anyway I think that his salary is
similar to a member of Congress about a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
okay so super chat is on and available
no super chats yet but I predict that we
will get some people still sort of
filtering in we have moderators we have
moderators which is good so that when
somebody starts going on a cockfest
saying I'm a Jew [ __ ] time and again I
don't have to get distracted and by the
way speaking of cucks i have i'm using
now to stream from my laptop with my
blue Yeti microphone and my HD webcam i
have the ability to generate all sorts
of graphics and all sorts of stuff so
like one example of something i can do
is something like this and i don't know
that i really need this for these live
streams but it does make it seem
somewhat more professional right when
you see a title pop up
like that I feel like it's doing
something for the professionalism of the
show although although I don't really
know what and I could also just I don't
know let's see I'll generate another one
I could also send messages to people
like please don't troll or something
like that and the other thing I have the
ability to do this is kind of cool i
guess i can draw on the screen but you
know i don't know how useful it really
would be I don't know if this is the
type of thing that would be useful to us
to have during a stream but I am I am
able to do it anyway let me get rid of
that and the other thing is I can also
just put text up on the screen but also
you know I just don't know I don't know
that we need any of this stuff but
anyway I have the ability to do some
things the other thing which could be
interesting is I can also generate a
split screen and I could potentially put
like if I'm discussing an article I
could put the article on the split
screen window I don't know maybe that
would be maybe that would be useful at
some point anyway I can't think of
anything to do with it right now so I'm
going to get back to I'm going to get
back to discussing some different topics
okay alright so I talked about the Trump
wiretap in the spice or press conference
here's my other thought about this as I
let me just take a sip here you can get
very thirsty during these live streams
clearly some of the antics that we're
seeing Donald Trump participate in are
meant to distract but what I don't know
is what are we trying to distract from
in other words are extraneous and
outrageous tweets meant to distract from
the Russia situation or are the
wiretapping allegations meant to
distract from the disastrous Republican
alternative to the Affordable Care Act
it's pretty clear that there's some
effort to focus public attention even
the Rachel Maddow and I have a long clip
on this I won't redo
the entire thing but even the rachel
maddow I don't know teas and and non
bombshell pho bombshell about the first
two pages of Donald Trump's 2005 1040
tax filings I think there's a very good
chance that that was leaked by Trump or
you know an associate of trumps what was
that meant to distract them like there's
so many scandals that I'm not sure
what's the worst one that is is meant to
be distracted from at this point and I'm
guessing people people probably have
thoughts on that like what's the worst
possible thing and also is anything
going well right now for Trump right i
mean it can we identify an area where
Trump is doing well I not that
progressives would agree with what he's
doing but even that you could argue he's
making progress i mean we saw i did the
story on today's show and you can you
can check it out on youtube and the
podcast already donald trump's second
attempt at a majority Muslim immigration
majority must majority Muslim country
immigration ban has also been halted now
by judges in Hawaii and I believe
Maryland so that's not going
particularly well building the wall
isn't going well the Obamacare repeal
isn't going well most of the jobs Trump
is taking credit for creating it's not
really economic policy that's creating
them it's just giving money to people
who plan to leave and and basically
saying will you stay if I give you money
it's not economic policy so I don't know
where we could argue Trump is actually
doing doing well here and if there's an
area you can point to by all means point
to it okay a couple thank-yous number
one big thank you to Ron habiger who has
signed up using the coupon code I voted
17 coupon code I vote at 17 gives you a
forty percent discount off of a David
Pakman show membership we've got
commercial free audio and video streams
of our full show for members we do a
daily extra show called the bonus show
for members and Ron habiger has opted to
sign up he gets a hundred percent of the
benefits but only pays sixty percent of
the membership costs also a big thank
you to Chris burrows Chris burrows has
just signed up
while I've been chatting with you here
at david pakman.com slash membership
please sign up it's our number one
funding source in addition of course to
our youtube partnership and i will do
live shout outs and thank yous as we go
here ok let me get to we have one super
chat so far we've got a two dollar super
chat from someone going by I believe
it's Lehman or maybe it's LeMond can you
show us the painting in the background
okay yeah let me grab that I'll see here
this is what i would consider some of my
earlier work let's see how i can do this
and get it aligned properly uh I can't
paint okay so this is one of my 2016
pieces certainly some of my earlier work
it's I consider it a landscape I call it
smiling clouds someone pointed out that
the clouds look sort of like a smiley
face and as you can tell I don't know
what I'm doing and if I actually get
closer you can see that from very far
away very far away it actually doesn't
look bad it actually looks like there
might be some coherence and you know
blending or whatever but when i put it
up close you can tell it's really a
disaster really a disaster but I call
the smiling clouds and it is it is in an
early 2016 piece from my collection
alright so hopefully that hopefully
that's of Isis I appreciate the the
super chat we've got a two dollar super
chat from Captain Cosmo bagel who has no
comment or question but thank you thank
you for sending the two-dollar super
chat we'll get back to super chats in a
little bit okay what else did I want to
talk about I want to talk a little bit
about so I'm thinking about slate just
put out actually it's not just late
there's been a bunch of different media
outlets that have been tracking Trump
lies and according to one tracker there
are now five hundred lies that have been
specifically attributed to Donald
then debunked so this doesn't even
include sort of the amorphous statements
that will likely end up not being true
but so far have not been designated as
lies but we're around 500 verified lives
for Donald Trump and I brought this
question up on the show the other day
and I haven't gotten a good answer and
maybe maybe in the chat people can give
me some some answers to this is there
any general area like a general you know
so for example health care or job
creation or I don't know vaccines you
pick whatever is there an area we can
say in this general area Donald Trump is
generally truthful accurate and
trustworthy I was thinking pretty hard
because I try to you know when there's
something positive that I can say and
saying that someone isn't a 100-percent
liar but only ninety-nine percent it's
not exactly the most positive thing but
you know we're in the Trump era silver
linings or what what we're trying to
find can anybody in the chat tell me of
a general area where we can say when
Trump talks about X you can generally
assume he's telling the truth I can't
think of an area obviously not health
care certainly not foreign policy
countless lies about what his positions
used to be what he'll do one selected
etc etc I just don't know of any area
where we can say hey on this issue
Donald Trump generally tells the truth
how much he's going to vacation how much
he's going to play golf I can't think of
anything and I see someone in the chat a
couple people talking about TPP Trump
hasn't been truthful about TPP Trump
took credit for getting the u.s. out of
TPP the US had never signed on to TPP
and the prospects for the u.s. signing
on to TPP were dead a while ago at best
this is most most charitably you could
stay that Trump had sation a banging on
to TPP but crafton Republicans a lot
like you had Democrats we're gonna like
against it it was dead on to go and try
calling his address joint session of
Congress that's not talking about DPP
that that is not think Donald Trump has
been truthful of bite by the very nature
of saying that is something I got it
sauder but that that's already live okay
we've got ten dollar super jet from deke
vote did you see this story about
foreign veteran being poor
I decorated veteran faces deportation
ring today united army it's pride
that means me
yes did see that other had an deeper
chat there was uh
I'm from our
this this story was turning in our
here morning
what type
etf
live streaming
check
you
and there was a story about some kind of
our
go but that was then night yeah so
stack of
with
correct
good
yeah I
very
free at
oh I don't these stories propping up
this prison and
is
this dude
as a
cost the moose and an immigration in
force because right
but
e
you
we
poor
uh
do
no court decree
be the
for
did and
if it was till
for
rate is all
to leave eagle
No
out very see if again
what oh
p
yes
just better
the
that
bye
the
Oh
Ben
to who
ah
bling yeah
you
what
as
there
not laugh
nah nah
very
if it did happen there's a coupon code
it's I
tips
for you
hey
we
Lee
I've
this
I
two
is it
yeah Oh
and
but
I
is
we all this
[ __ ]
right
dick so
you
Oh
this
but
nah look
he
that
right
two
I'm
like
No
ah
ok
and
did you know
this
do
I
so
e
and if
we
but
what
you
you
good
it is
that is
you
my
to kill
t
booze
sir
the
when
No
they're very exciting
No
we've just booked a couple more
interviews and some of these I think
people are really really going to like
let me deal with that and then we'll get
to some of the other super chats we have
coming up all right on Monday I'm going
to be interviewing Jamie Sampson Jamie
Sampson has written a book called how to
think like a scientist and I've talked
before about the importance of I took
seriously about a year and a half ago
when i received a few emails from people
saying David I like when you report on
science stories but you should learn a
little more about the right ways to
report on science stories okay and so I
took that seriously and took time to
read about better science related
reporting Jamie Samson is going to join
me to talk about as consumers of media
and science and tech stories what are
some ways that we should be thinking
like scientists when we read a story
about science or technology and then
that's going to be Monday and Tuesday
two-part interview Wednesday and
Thursday I am thrilled to tell you that
theoretical physicists and cosmologists
Lawrence Krauss is going to be back on
the program and we're going to have a
nice long two-part interview with him
probably a half hour or 35 minutes total
he has a new book called the greatest
story ever told so far please so we're
going to focus the interview on that
book but that book encompasses many many
different things so if you have
questions related to even tangentially
what's in that book by all means send
them in and I will get your questions to
Lawrence Krauss then and this is this is
really a big get and let me see if I
have the book here I do I talked
recently about how I've been
damn
but
back
the
you
right
you
so
the
right
the
Oh
whoo
right
the
you
is
check
t
sir
Oh
color first
right
you
just
make it
oops
Oh
d
you
help
you
look
it's a
buddy
yes
is it
as
fine Oh
what
you
that apps so
be
just
cry
subreddit
you
did
but I
doctor
hey
yup
Oh
it sucks
oh and I
it
are your hobbies I breathe
ha ha
yes I
he's
never
ha
yeah but don't
what
p
did
ok
what
okay some cheap
nah
No
Oh
yes
the elders Weaver has some
just
good yeah
d
to please
that's up to
chill
everything